bonjour à tous bienvenue bienvenue sur
france 24 dans ce journal entièrement
consacré à ce cinquième jour d'invasion
russe de l'ukraine on l'a appris il ya
quelques instants mans civils ont été
tués dans des bombardements russes à
kharkiv kharkiv c'est la deuxième ville
d'ukraine informations données par le
gouverneur de la région ville que les
soldats d'ukrainiens disent avoir repris
londres condamnent fermement cette
attaque les observateurs ont pu regarder
les vidéos de cet événement depuis ce
matin est avec nous pour en parler en
plateau thomas et doux bonjour thomas
qu'est ce que vous avez pu trouver en
regardant cette vidéo qui circule sur de
ses bombardements sur kharkiv est bien
effectivement nous avons regardé ce
qu'il s'est passé à kharkhiv ce matin
nous avons analysé deux séquences la
première c'est une frappe qui ait eu
lieu au nord-est de la ville à côté d'un
centre commercial nous avons aussi
regardé des débris de roquettes qui ont
été vus pas très loin de cette attaque
et donc nous allons commencer par l'
attaque tout d'abord nous avons regardé
cette vidéo qui étaient filmées à
kharkhiv on peut y voir une attaque à la
roquette avec de nombreuses explosions
qui ont lieu quasi simultanément on les
voit sur ces images alors on ne connaît
pas la nature exacte de cette attaque
mais il est possible que ce soit ce
qu'on appelle des sous munitions c'est à
dire plein de petites bombes qui sont
largués par une seule et même vos quêtes
cela sert habituellement pour déminer
par exemple mais c'est strictement
interdit dans les utiliser sur des zones
civiles nous avons aussi vu cette
seconde vidéo que nous avons authentifié
et qui a été filmé au même endroit à
kharkhiv là encore on voit le même type
d' attaque avec de multiples explosions
que l'on peut voir en fond sur cette
image les deux vidéos ont été filmés ici
tout près d'un centre commercial dans le
nord-est donc de la ville on peut voir
sur cette image satellite on le voit ici
en verre en rouge c'est la zone ciblée
sur les deux vidéos nous avons regardé
donc sur google quelle était cette zone
entouré en rouge c'est écrit que ce sont
des entrepôts et des parkings de
voitures en revanche les explosions
n'ont pas toutes eu lieu dans cette zone
rouge où on a pu en apercevoir autour de
cette zone l'organisation
gouvernementale
non gouvernementale human rights watch a
déjà recensé lé usage de bombes à sous
munitions jeudi dernier et donc une
frappe qui jeudi dernier avait tué
quatre civils en avaient blessé une
dizaine
alors qu'en est-il à propos de ces
roquettes qui n'ont pas explosé que l'on
a vu dans les rues de kharkiv en plein
milieu d'habitations des civils eh bien
nous avons tout d'abord authentifier
cette vidéo qui a été tournée à côté des
deux premières qui montrait les frappes
on peut y voir le reste d'une requête
aux plantes est juste ici au milieu
d'eux au milieu de la rue avec une
voiture et des passants qui qui passe
juste à côté il existe également cette
autre vidéo qui a été filmé à quelques
mètres de celle-ci on petit voir le même
mode est de requêtes mais cette fois ci
de plus près c'est un modèle bien connu
dans l'inventaire russe cette partie de
la requête que nous voyons c'est
l'arrière de l'objet nous avons pris une
même image pour comparer les deux objets
c'est un lance roquettes multiple de
fabrication soviétique qui tient qui
tire ses requêtes là et donc pour
répondre à cette question ces débris de
roquettes que nous avons vu dans la
ville de kharkiv ne sont pas forcément
des munitions qui n'ont pas explosé cela
peut être tout simplement une partie de
la roquette qui retombent après avoir
largué sa charge ou ces chargements
merci beaucoup tomato mind donc que du
ca a été observateur pour ce un
décryptage plus